the army came out in full force for bts
at the mtv video music awards
the super group won two awards group of
the year and best kpop video and the vma
goes to
bts
bts couldn't be in brooklyn to accept
their awards in person but after their
hit song butter won best k-pop video
they offered up an acapella performance
as a treat
bts also took a moment to shout out to
their beloved army of loyal fans here we
are
thank you for this honor sorry we
couldn't be there but hopefully next
time we will
we feel so blessed and grateful for all
the love we received this year
shout out to me the best people in the
world
will keep bringing great music and
pokemons for you guys love you all love
you and who better to give out this
award to today's biggest group than
three boy band icons in saints lance
bass backstreet boys aj mclean and 98
degrees nick lachey
bts could not be here tonight but they
sent a message to all their loyal fans
i'm gonna take this home with me thank
you there's lance getting in one more
laugh before his life gets turned upside
down in the near future that's right i
got twins on the way they could come any
day now take a good look this is the
last time you see this guy arrested
so never be at the vmas for the next 18.
so you know aj works for either baby
that's a it's a great name
bts opened up to et earlier this year
about the magic behind butter i'm so
excited to see you guys oh i see the
butter everywhere
oh tell me why this song is called
butter what can we expect
yes sir and you can see the color of
butter on on his hair perfect you're
matching the vibe um you know we say
smooth like butter will it will this
song have people moving smooth like
butter
of course
you are of course killing it how does it
feel for you emotionally to break record
after record with your music
yeah he was so good